so let's talk about levels of cops
that's the first thing you should
mention those the second thing is this
excess business what's this about now
we've looked in excess in the comic
context of our youth allowance right
access is for what is excess in a
context within that it's a little bit
over over in Bob like some threshold ok
so the ID he is let's just go right for
me on the top level ok if you pay this
amount per we perform at per month it's
quite a bit per year right that means
when you arrived at hospital no matter
what procedure you go through you don't
have to pay anything extra like this
this will cover you no matter what
happens however like that's a lot of
money maybe you don't want to surrender
that amount of money all the time and
frankly you reckon I'm a pretty low risk
for actually get a name like these kinds
of procedures right you might go through
something like this so intermediate
hospital access what that means is if
you go in right you're coming for a
certain number of procedures but suppose
the procedure costs I load three hundred
dollars okay like say you need an x-ray
or you've gotta get an MRI done all this
cost money ok and they say look the bill
for this is three hundred dollars ok
your insurance fund who you're paying on
this stuff too maybe you're a level one
they say will cover the first two
hundred fifty dollars for you ok but
there's an excess of fifty dollars
you've got over the threshold you're
going to have to pay that out of your
pocket ok this idea in excess it's also
called you should notice till it's also
called a gap right in fact if you don't
like it say
go to the physio green onion or if you
go to a dentist you're probably to have
insurance cover and then they pay for
some of your procedure but then there's
a gap payment like there's a little bit
extra it's like what we got to teach so
you had more feelings than I expected so
you need to pay a little bit extra to
cover that you can see if you want to
have higher levels right sorry so this
one here is that you might have to pick
up to a thousand dollars right or up to
five hundred dollars and the higher you
go up don't more you have to pay so
these kinds of things talk about well
how much support and we're going to get
and how much you're going to pay am I
going to pay for that privilege in some
ways everything in insurance is a gamble
right it's like or how risky is it that
I'm going to have to go through this
procedure or that procedure I might want
to sort of take a bit of risk or you
might say no no you know what i like my
knees been terrible like my whole life
so I'm just going to need to have high
cover because I know it's going to need
ongoing treatment does that make sense
ok so that's all about these levels
alright so I want to run this off now we
talked about number one we talked about
levels of our cover number two we talked
about excess number three we need to
look not vertically but horizontally
haven't looked across this rifle when
you look at all of these different
columns there are two overarching plot
and then there are a bunch of some
columns right so the first one is direct
debit or payroll deduct deduction and
the other one is advance pay you guys
can probably work out just by what they
call what do you think each one means
what are you guessing this one is yeah
so what this means is either you're just
going to pay it immediately or they just
take it out of your pay every time you
get paid they're just going to take off
a little child and that's kind of
convenient cuz that you don't have to
worry about money in money out you don't
have to worry about the University
Covenant what am I gonna am I gonna lose
on that what you're getting is straight
away you're going to need okay so that's
a payroll deduction and people will get
pay on different basis so that's why the
more frequently we pay are the different
events that again you can see it by the
way like fortnightly versus weekly which
one is better value have a look at your
calculator like a four days two weeks
right so what's 25.6 four times to wait
is it 15.1 51.2 a 21 and 28 sets yeah
your internet so now it's not much of a
margin is it like it's a pretty smug
that one wait it's yeah well it's it's a
sin but over like in a bank account like
there's not gonna be any rounding really
like they're just gonna take off the
exact no sense yeah dear is that here
like your kind of holding off payment
right here it's like a fortnight boom I
have two weeks of money i'm going to
hand that to them straight away okay but
here it's like no no i need to hold on
to my money here as long as I possibly
can let me keep it don't pay on a
fortnightly basis let me hold on to it
so as you have further to the right
you're paying increasingly large amounts
of all of one so you don't have access
to that money and more right so this
would be for instance widest are you in
January are they paying what does 310
dollars and then I never have to pay for
most of the year what would be the
advantage of doing
after two it's going to be cheaper right
like the insurance phone is going to be
like sweet we'll take all your money
therefore will give you a bit of a
discount the insurer is fun wants this
to happen okay what'd be the
disadvantaged students why would you not
do this it just yeah it's gone like you
know that money that we're seeing you're
making out now it's not that any
interest for you anymore because the
insurance like I said right so as you go
this way you gets a whole lot of ammo
longer but they make you pay for the
privilege advance that you can see it
has nothing to do with your page like
when you get your pay it's just like on
a on a more long scale I'm just going to
pay them up songs ahead of time so a lot
of what's being looked at here is what
are the levels of color what am I going
to get for it and what benefits are
there two going down this way or going
that way across a mediator again read
the tables fairly carefully is it does
that mean that one so it's level three
more expensive okay so no fiddling
around so let me try and clarify could
maybe maybe I didn't be careful you can
see let's just go with me see you can
see that this level three is the lowest
level it's the cheapest level to see
that right and as you go up you're
paying more in fact by the anti-japan
like fifty percent more okay what that
means is your excess can be very very
hard okay it's just like I go in for a
procedure and you know it costs this
about money you may have to pick be out
of pocket up to a thousand dollars all
in one here like if you're in a car
accident and all I've got is basic
hospital access on this level you might
have to pay a thousand dollars to get
you all the x-rays done at your
send what happened okay and for however
many days they actually to stay in
hospital that is the amount got out of
pocket okay whereas if I go to this
level I've got to pay more each time
right but if I'd actually in the
hospital my excess will be lower right I
won't after I won't have so much out
whereas you can go all the right way up
around at the top which is that no
matter how much my procedure costs
because I've paid so much in advance
they'll just they'll just waive that fee
i'll say yeah you're sure is fun to
cover the entire job